au sud du chili
el chino tuyaux et flash s'aventure seul
dans les canaux de patagonie
au sud de la nouvelle zélande collines
et ses hommes sont les derniers pêcheurs
de langoustes de l'histoire
[Musique]
à première vue rien ne les rassemble
et sont séparés de milliers de
kilomètres ils n'ont pas les mêmes
moyens ne gagne pas les mêmes sommes
[Musique]
et pourtant tout les rapproche
ils font l'un des métiers les plus
dangereux dans des endroits qui compte
parmi les plus risqués du monde
[Musique]
il partage le danger le froid isolement
dans ces latitudes chacun de leur voyage
est une aventure
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
on est arrivés bien trop tôt à punta
arenas au chili on avait rendez vous
avec un équipage
on l'a attendu pendant une semaine
personne n'avait une nouvelle personne
ne savait où l'été et un jour là sarita
est apparu à la mi temps c'était mon
père donc c'est rien c'est comme ça
qu'on a rencontré el chino
elle tue et flash
[Applaudissements]
sur un port enneigées de puntarenas où
ils sont rentrés bredouilles sans un
ours
[Musique]
la nuit tombe sur la ville ils ne savent
pas trop quoi faire
mais cet échec à creuser des dettes il
faut repartir vite dans les deux jours
il ya tuyaux l'oncle parce qu'il n'a pas
d'enfant mais une ribambelle de nos
voeux et de nice
il y à flash le plongeur il vit seul à
punta arenas et doit son surnom à sa
rapidité d'exécution et el chino le
capitaine qui habite une petite maison
avec toute sa famille au pied d'un
centre commercial
et enfin il ya le doux agneaux il ne
partira pas avec eux elle vaut when you
et l'harmonie combattants mais comment
ça va carlito bien il est où le trio on
va les chercher
il y avait hier la plaie il faut aller
chercher l'homme principal l'homme clé
elles ont déclaré qu'ils allaient partir
à 3 parce que là ça s'est très mal passé
mais cette fois ci il faudra pas que ce
soit le cas toutes vos campagnes vaut
pas de mauvaise quand même mal quand je
te disais ça peut pas tout en négatif
ils se sont donné rendez-vous dans la
maison du capitaine et chino ils font la
liste d'avitaillement escudé derniers
détails
ce disque cette fois ci il faut que ça
marche c'est ce que je leur dis toujours
par à 3 on part de la maison mais on
sait jamais quand on va revenir
ça sert à rien d'être fâché faut juste y
mettre de la bonne volonté
c'est à cette seule condition que le
boulot se passera bien
là on part avec la fois je crois que ce
voyage va bien se passer
ouais on a la foi et surtout l'attrait
soir ouais il faut boire beaucoup avant
de partir
[Musique]
la sarita appareils deux jours après son
retour
la sarita un petit bateau en bois solide
qui tient bien la mère paraît-il
[Applaudissements]
l'aca rita et sa cabine d'à peine 4
mètres carrés dans laquelle il faut
dormir manger
en un mot vivre et où se joue une forme
de huit lits permanents pour les trois
hommes
la précédente pêche a été catastrophique
pour se refaire el chino tuyaux et flash
ont décidé de tenter leur chance dans un
endroit où on peut se rendre le canal à
bras pour y aller il faut commencer par
remonter le détroit de magellan
[Applaudissements]
le temps en ce moment est variable non
il peut changer d'ici la nuit dans cette
région ils changent environ toutes les
six heures avec la marée aulas
le
ça va se gâter
je crois qu'il va pleuvoir au mieux le
disait la météo 50 60 70 km/heure de
langues
pendant toute la nuit et une bonne
partie de la matinée
ils essaient de franchir le cap froward
le point le plus australe du continent
américain
là le détroit de magellan forme un coude
et les vents dominants viennent de face
sur les sacrifices qu'on fait pour
garder sa femme
avec ce boulot au moins je suis sûr
qu'on va garder nolan à l etoile bateau
arrête de cogner arrête dans
d'abord allez arrête de cogner
la sarita souffre
le moteur fait 80 chevaux la puissance
d'une petite berline et il faut
affronter des mers former des forts
courants
ça ne va pas passer
ici c'est pas le patron qui décide tout
seul si on passe ou pas on est 3 alors
on décide ensemble de continuer ou de
s'arrêter
on la sent l'herbe des saignées morgan
am non parce que s'il arrive quelque
chose à l'un d'entre nous c'est pâques à
lui que ça arrive aussi à tous les trois
et six à une tempête on va pas prendre
le risque d'un naufrage lorsque le plus
souvent ya pas de bateau proche pour
venir nous sauver
les trois hommes décident de se mettre à
l'abri
ici dans les canaux de patagonie la
météo rythme la progression et le
travail
quand le temps est mauvais on se cache
on fait le dos rond on attend que ça
passe
[Musique]
ça va durer trois jours
voilà la loi l'eau je m'entends fort et
clair je t'entends bien on a la même
info pour la météo l'après midi
s'annonce très mauvaise vers 6h 7h ça
peut changer
on sait jamais vous n'avez pas le choix
ou attendre serviront à ces deux mois
c'est en fait les prévisions sont
mauvaises on en a parlé avec un autre
bateau qui venait de puerto natales aise
pour punta arenas disent que c'est très
mauvais on va attendre le soir vers 20
heures et on va voir l'évolution est il
vraiment la dévotion cas là j'espère que
ça change vers le nord-ouest pour que ce
soit favorable pour nous dernier voyage
s'est très mal passé on a foiré
on est resté dix douze jours dehors sans
pouvoir rien faire on est revenu à vide
le temps était très mauvais donc on a eu
que dalle
à toi selon p deyglun et l'ambiance
étant d'équipage ça va le colombien bien
écoute ici tout va bien elle donnait
tous les trois et le trio carlo et moi
ces gens viennent pour l'ambiance avant
qui nie pour l'instant les états d'âme
ça va on peut y arriver
[Musique]
kima probable et mais la coca
il y est bien d'offrir à nos atouts et
carla nord-ouest des pays-bas y dénombre
conduit votre maison contre lui la météo
avec le rapport il sera totalement
couvert avec les gens de 100
kilomètres/heure et de la neige et un
témoin il faut tenter le coup demain
matin sinon
c'est au fond oui mais ça va changer
demain matin ça peut changer en quelques
secondes alors que les trois chiliens
espèrent enfin passé le cap froward pour
poursuivre leur chemin au sud de la
nouvelle zélande près de l'île stewart
collines et ces deux hommes d'équipage
fond de la vague moteur de 1000 chevaux
lancé pleine balle ils sont les derniers
pêcheurs de langoustes de lille
y a personne en mer j'adore ça
mon père était pêcheur lorsque j'avais 7
ans
on est parti pour deux semaines en mer
et c'est sans doute à ce moment là que
j'ai commencé à aimer ce métier
cette vie après je me rappelle qu'elle
est poste d'équipage me payer
l'équivalent de 20 centimes pour chaque
jour où je n'étais pas malade
c'est leur a pas coûté cher et puis
après pendant les vacances scolaires
continuer à suivre mon père ambition
c'était d'avoir mon propre bateau pour
aller pêcher et 40 ans voilà entrain
[Musique]
cela fait maintenant deux jours que
coline et ses matelots sillonnent le sud
de l'histoire
en cette fin de saison il espère relever
leurs casiers allant boost juste avant
la tempête qui se profile à l'horizon
la saison a été plutôt bonne
et sur le pont arrière queen et jason
s'apprête à bosser
ils ne sont pas très causants il faut
dire que pendant près de douze heures
d'affilée ils ne vont pas arrêter retour
au boulot les gars
[Musique]
la cadence est extrêmement soutenu
il faut d'abord placé les a pas dans les
casiers
les jeter à la mer avant de relever
d'autres quasi un peu plus loin
[Musique]
elle crève défense et des fioles tu sais
c'est un peu les charognards de la mer
il suffit de mettre les bons appels et
le tour est joué
casting mais il ya certaines périodes
dans l'année où elles ne veulent pas
entrer dans les pièges et c'est en
général quand elles pour leur mue elle
change de carapace moment de leur vie
elles sont vraiment faim et c'est bien
plus facile de les attraper
il ne faut surtout pas se fier aux
apparences à la pêche à la langouste il
ne suffit pas de jeter ses pièges à la
mer au petit bonheur la chance et les
récolter quelques jours plus tard sans
être une science
il faut de la précision déposez le
casier à l'endroit exact où les
langoustes se rassemblent au pied des
falaises sous marins
à la barre coline joue sans cesse avec
les courants avec la houle avant de
choisir le moment précis pour larguer
ses casiers
il n'est pas difficile de comprendre
pourquoi il est le dernier à pêcher la
langouste par ici tous les autres ont
abandonné à cause de l'éloignement à
cause des risques
la mairie est toujours démonter le
danger permanent
le pire qui puisse arriver c'est que
l'un d'entre nous tombent à la mer qu'on
se fasse accrocher dans l'un des
cordages c'est leur boulot de veiller
l'un sur l'autre
moi je ne veux pas quitter mon poste
pour le tir à la croche toi ici de toute
façon ils connaissent bien le bateau ils
me connaissent ils connaissent la
manière dont je gère les manoeuvres mais
c'est chacun pour soi sur le pont à
l'arrière
aujourd'hui les cases et qu'il remonte à
bord sont bien remplies
les langoustes pleuvent sur le pont
c'est byzance même si leur jette à la
mer près de la moitié d'entre elles il
est trop petit
celles prêtes à pondre
pour toutes celles là les pêcheurs ont
l'obligation de ne pas les conserver à
bord alors il balance encore et encore
lors d'une marée queen et jason ne
comptent pas leurs efforts ils
n'arrêtent jamais sont toujours d'attac
il faut dire que le salaire est bonne
très bon mais le métier du très dur
ce n'est pas eux qui diront le contraire
alors qu'ils entendent de loin on
nouvelle pas très engageante à la radio
une tempête se dirige vers le sud de
l'île stewart à l'endroit même où ils se
trouvent il prévoit un prêt de 130 km
heure devant cet après midi alors il va
falloir improviser
mais apparemment les prévisions sont
plutôt juste en ce moment
pour l'instant ça va même si je vous
avoue que 130 kilomètres/heure ça
commence à faire beaucoup
c'est vraiment le cas on verra bien ce
qu'on fait
oh
[Musique]
et
en patagonie el chino tuyaux et flash
ont franchi le cap froward après trois
jours à se planquer du mauvais temps
il continue de progresser vers le canal
à bras mais un détail bien les troubler
[Musique]
c'est plein de haut en bas les patates
sont trempés le m de ventes
il y à de l'eau dans la cale ce n'est
pas en soi une très bonne nouvelle mais
après avoir mis autant de temps pour
arriver dans leur zone de pêche
les trois hommes préfèrent se focaliser
sur le but de leur voyage
les oursins
non non
non
qui au balancement
flash revêt alors sa combinaison de 20
mm d'épaisseur l'eau est à 2 degrés
papus dehors il fait à peine zéro degré
ici je suis sûre qu'il ya de grosses
oursins
el chino etios à faire sur l'antique
compresseur la machine la plus
importante du bord elle envoie l'air à
flash qui plonge au narguilé
et toi quelque chose de bien chaud dans
les chaussettes
première plongée dans le canal à brax
quatre jours pour venir jusque là et
tout ça pour quoi
les heures non [__] il fait froid ça
vous y'a rien y'a pas d'ours à ils sont
trop petits
on va bouger là bas c'est un peu plus
profond
c'est un travail d'aventurier des fois
tu gagnes beaucoup des fois rien du tout
parce qu'il faut souffrir pour avoir des
oursins
maire de temps commence à se gâter oui
mais il ya plein d'autres ça il y en a
des petits aussi souvent
il peut se faire de l'argent avec ça
cette fois on n'a pas le choix
bien les choisir il partit à l'eau
il faut que je prends des médicaments
pour les nerfs et je dois prendre un
calmant qu'on me détendre bien avec eux
ils font attention à moi
ils sont très attentifs aux cuirs parce
que c'est dans l'hélice du bateau peut
l'attraper et la radio un vieux plongeur
[Musique]
là tu peux avancer
vérifiez bien la taille des ours un
faucon et à manger quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai juste regarder les autres faire
mais un jour un plongeur m'a appris
alors oui j'avais mal aux oreilles
je ne savais même pas nager et celui qui
ne sait pas nager encore plus de mal à
plonger c'est comme ça que j'aime bien
plonger brink's et ça fait 20 ans que je
fais ce métier nivet apprendre à
travailler sous l'eau c'est l'expérience
qui vous apprend comment faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien
il ya plein tour ça
oh
je commence à me faire vieux mois
un jour mon tuyau s'est cassé alors que
je cherchais des moules
on les prenait 1,20 m de profondeur et
ça c'était une bêtise parce que les gars
en surface remonter le tuyau avec des
filets bien trop remplie et le tuyau n'a
pas supporté le poids
il s'est cassé et le filet a commencé à
m'emporter au fond je commande là j'ai
lâché les plombs mais comme j'étais
chargé j'en suis pas remettre tout de
suite qu'on peut savoir pour la dune
décompresser je suis resté un certain
temps sous le choc
avec le temps j'ai oublié
la récolte de la journée n'est
finalement pas si mauvaise les choses
semblent enfin bien tourner flash
inspecter la coque
c'est pour ailleurs bas
il ya même plus de fibres
il ya un trou comme ça sans fibre il est
tout gratter
[__] c'est pas vrai
ce trou est certainement à l'origine de
la voie d'eau et ce n'est pas un très
bon présage
les trois hommes semblent inquiets ici
personne ne leur viendra en aide
[Musique]
au sud de l'île stewart collines se
prépare pour la tempête
il faut agir vite prendre la bonne
décision pour sauvegarder ces captures
et langouste récoltés depuis quatre
jours risque de s'abîmer se blesser
entre elles autrement dit elles vont
perdre de la valeur
ce qui n'est pas vraiment le bus si
collines et ses hommes prennent des
risques
c'est aussi parce qu'ils peuvent gagner
beaucoup d'argent
[Musique]
à
en général je ne pêche que pour une
seule usine elle machette tout mêlant
boost mais en ce moment toutes les
usines refusent notre pêche à cause des
fluctuations du marché
il ya beaucoup de concurrence sur le
marché chinois aujourd'hui alors juste
avant que nous ne partions en mer j'ai
contacté l'unique acheteur du coin terme
il a promis de prendre ma marchandise
cela fait plusieurs heures que coline
essaie de joindre son succès son amie
jane dans cette partie du globe
les pêcheurs isolé utilise parfois les
services d'un hélicoptère pour acheminer
leurs langoustes vivante jusqu'à l'
usine de conditionnement et sur stewart
island
zain est le seul pilote à remplir cette
mission
je pense que la capacité à travailler
dans ce genre d'environnement au style
vient du fait qu'on est né ici qu'on a
grandi sur sept est utile et collines et
moi on a joué très tôt sur de petits
bateaux
cela nous a appris la manière de gagner
notre vie dans ces conditions météos
excécrables tout cela ne peut pas
s'apprendre en deux temps trois
mouvements
parce qu'ici la mer et le vent peuvent
s'enlever la vie c'est une de mes filles
intestines
j'ai pas réussi à joindre collins et je
les appelais pourtant ce matin à 7
heures je crois que son téléphone est
cassée mais j'espère qu'elle est prêt là
je compte sur une courte fenêtre météo
parce que le temps est vraiment merdique
aujourd'hui avec un peu de chance je
vais pas volé pour rien
après plusieurs tentatives colline
réussit enfin à joindre au design
il lui donne alors des indications
précises sur sa position et des éléments
sur le temps qu'il fait dans le sud de
l'île stewart ajkai sera bien pas de
souci pour moi je vais préparer mon
matériel et puis j'arrive
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je décide de ne pas voler pour aller
chercher notre cargaison langouste a
fait je pense que les pêcheurs respecte
ma décision
ils ne veulent pas que je prenne des
risques inconsidérés pour ramener leurs
langoustes l usine
je crois qu'il me respecte aussi parce
que j'ai une histoire à la pêche je sais
lire le temps et parfois je ne veux pas
me mettre en péril ou perdre les
cargaisons de mangouste forêt seine
alors quand je dis non il ya bien trop
de vent personne ne se plaint il n'y a
pas de pression
c'est ma décision et cette fois-ci zen a
décidé d'y aller sur leur aura australis
ont fait une pause en attendant les
opérations de levage
en général à la fin de la saison on en a
ras-le-bol du bateau antibes et une fois
que tu es chez toi pendant une semaine
c'était trouve n'importe quelle excuse
pour retourner à bord
on passe vraiment beaucoup de temps sur
le bateau ce navire c'est un peu comme
ma femme si j'ose dire
coline essaie de trouver un abri pendant
que jane survolent l'île
zain connaît les risques qu'ils prennent
zain les apps lui aussi il est à nancy
un pêcheur de langoustes
j'ai beaucoup d'amis et de proches qui
ont perdu la vie dans ces barrages
autour d'eux les oies ou dans le détroit
de fauveau cela arrive de temps à voir
surtout quand les gens jouent avec les
limites il se retrouve vite dans des
conditions extrêmes beaucoup d'entre eux
n'ont jamais été retrouvés à cause des
conditions climatiques
le vent et les courants marins et ses
risques
en voilà la raison
[Musique]
voici un exemple parfait une langouste
de grosse taille mais d'une nouvelle
zélande
c'est un mal à peu près 1 kg s'il vous
70 dollars nous évidemment on pense
qu'il en vaut bien plus c'est vraiment
un beau spécimen
c'est exactement ce que les
consommateurs recherchent regardez moi
ça c'est vraiment un bel animal il est
très bien dessiné dieu n'a t-il pas bien
fait les choses
zane arrive au dessus de l'aurora
australis
mais la mission est difficile
mais rafales de vent sont fortes
imprévisible
design aussi chevronné soit il va devoir
s'y reprendre à plusieurs fois pour
hisser les linguistes
en patagonie flash le plongeur a repéré
un trou dans la coque du sarita ils sont
isolés dans le canal à bras il faut
trouver une solution avec les moyens du
bord
pour maintenant
il a presque failli te le diras flash
qu'il faut qu'ils se préparent contre
pendant que moi je malaxe un peu plus
cette pâte là
étant donné seulement la moitié d'accord
est juste un peu comme ça tu pourrais
mieux travailler en bas mais non
[Musique]
les sept jours si vite surtout que là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
cette merde se décolle oui alors à la
pas la même quand ils appliquent bien
j'ai déjà serré j'ai tout fait j'ai tout
essayé ça ne colle pas sur la coque
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on essaye
avec celle là on essaye de bien l'étaler
par tous deux bien acérées tu vois tu le
faire bien
[Musique]
pourquoi cette merde ne colle pas je
sais pas c'est bizarre qu'elle colle pas
sur la coque c'est fait pour ça j'ai
essayé de bien la colle et gelé bien
rentrer dedans ça se décolle quand même
et un mode ya beaucoup d'espacé entre
les planches un petit peu un petit peu
un petit peu bon alors comment on va
faire on n'a pas le choix on va laisser
les choses comme ça le gros problème
c'est qu'on a préparé toute la partie je
pensais que ça allait marcher du premier
coup moi
et comme si ça ne suffisait pas il brise
une antenne en s'amarrant à un arbre
une vraie journée de merde
1 c'est pas vrai lâche le lâche le
qu'est ce qui se passe avec l'antenne
le prix de l'or par les tarawih les
mains sur la cabine a cassé
donc
attention annonce est bientôt celle où
là comme ça ça devrait tenir là non on
va dire
[Musique]
merde alors il fait froid ou par la mena
le capitaine réparé échappement du
moteur faut qu'ils se dépêchent parce
que si je me déshabille vous allez être
effrayé car oui non
m
c'est beaucoup de sacrifices pour ce
qu'on nous paye beaucoup de sacrifices
parce qu'ici il ya du vent il ya de la
pluie
et puis on est loin de son foyer que sa
famille de ses enfants
c'est inquiétant pour nous voir qu'ils
nous payent pas assez pour tout ce que
ça représente ce boulot celle par
exemple pour ses tours 5
les clients des usines les achète une
vingtaine de rôles kilos qu'il met à
nous on nous l'achète 10 euros le kilo
donc pour nous c'est une mauvaise
opération
alors que pour les autres c'est tout
bénef mais qu'est ce qui les fait tenir
comment gère-t-il ces situations comment
arrive-t-il a toujours gardé le sourire
non sinon c'est mort c'est vrai parfois
je me fasse bloquer quoi parce que quand
tu pars et que tu arrives ici par
exemple tu vois que bloquer et cinq six
jours ballottés tu t'inquiètes forcément
boîte mais bon moi je montre pas que je
suis de mauvaise humeur
même si je suis très en colère je vais
pas le montrer parce que je veux pas que
mes compagnons soient mal à l'aise moi
je suis le capitaine celui qui le
responsable si moi je déprime pour eux
ça va être très difficile donc je
préfère regarder tout ça pour moi ne
rien montrer de mes inquiétudes depuis
le départ jusqu'au retour j'essaie de
garder la bonne humeur
raide et le mauvais sort s'acharne sur
les pêcheurs d'oursins du sarita
pourtant ils font contre mauvaise
fortune bon coeur
c'est sûr demain sera jours meilleurs
[Musique]
en nouvelle zélande une manoeuvre
délicate est en cours
après quatre tentatives zane le pilote
d'hélicoptère
s'apprête enfin à soulever les 600 kilos
de langoustes pour les acheminer vers l'
usine de conditionnement
l'hélicoptère a une limite de charge et
si on dépasse cette limite
l'appareil a bien moins de puissance
dans les manoeuvres et si vous essayez
de soulever une charge dans le gros
temps il faut vraiment faire très
attention être délicat pour ne pas
endommager le matériel et prendre des
risques
une erreur au dessus de cet océan
peut-être fatale les langoustes de
collines rejoignent usine de dunes et
d'îles d'où elles repartiront par avion
vers hong kong
là bas on les attend vivante pour les
évaluer
[Musique]
on se dirige vers un petit abri que je
connais bien on n'imagine pas qu'il
existe des endroits calmes par ici vous
allez voir un mouillage agréable pour la
nuit
pour la première fois on sent collines
et ces sommes soulagés la soirée va
faire du bien
un peu de repos
penser à autre chose
avec toujours dans un coin de la tête
quand même l'espoir que le prix du
marché en chine soit à la hauteur de
leurs efforts
on a récolté 700 kilos de langoustes
aujourd'hui c'est mieux que rien c'est
pas mal même ça fait combien de dollars
tout ça pour cette question s'il faut
que tu demandes à kolin
et maintenant c'est le moment de se
reposer un peu et puis c'est l'heure de
la bière pourquoi c'est l'heure de la
bière et puis quand vous aurez partout à
en découdre
je crois qu'on va se saouler assez vite
ce soir on a sorti en 179 casier
multiplier 140 kg ça fait 25 tonnes j'ai
l'impression que la compétition est rude
et que vous avez tendance à garder vos
petits secrets
les pêcheurs de requins passent leur
temps à la radio pour dire combien de
prise ils ont fait les pêcheurs de
langoustes c'est silence radio
on ne parle pas ne se passe rien
[Musique]
la soirée l'alcool les rires tout semble
avoir été réparateur pour les trois
hommes de l'aurora australis
le lendemain la mère est encore plus
agitées encore plus démonté et les
hommes encore plus vaillants
plein de gens sur cette terre on déboule
au blizzard ou dangereux
mais pour moi la belge c'est le seul
métier que je connais c'est ce que j'ai
toujours voulu faire repartir en mer
mais moi si
[Musique]
alors ce sont toujours les mêmes gestes
les a pas que l'on fixe dans les casiers
les quasi que l'on jette les autres que
l'on remonte
et langouste que l'on trie celles qui
restent à bord celle que l'on balance
toujours les mêmes gestes dans une mer
où il faut être marin pour tenir debout
à oman dans le petit port de l'île
stewart dans la grande maison blanche
sarah la femme de collines et sans
nouvelle de son mari depuis plusieurs
jours la communication est souvent
difficile et vu la météo elle a du mal à
cacher son inquiétude
alors oui allô bonjour comment vas tu il
a neigé sur le mans england sais pas il
fait très froid
si sarah peut enfin parler à kolin c'est
par ce qui n'est déjà plus très loin du
port
il fait route vers la maison depuis
quelques heures
[Musique]
toi aussi tu as eu la foudre et les
éclairs par là bas ici on a eu un gros
orage avec des éclairs il était quelle
heure 7 heures du matin je crois mais tu
devais être encore en train de pêcher me
suis aperçu de rien il faisait très
sombre portant
[Musique]
en tous les cas je suis content d'être
là
[Musique]
dans l'extrême sud de la nouvelle
zélande collines a terminé la saison de
langoustes une bonne saison il a bien
gagné sa vie quelques semaines de repos
l'attendent quelques bières aussi avec
son ami zen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les canaux de patagonie il fait un
froid glacial
il a neigé de rue durant la nuit et une
bonne couche de neige recouvre le coup
tu augmentes de se casser la figure dans
la cale ça le fait sourire mais on sent
bien que l'ambiance se tend à bord de l'
sarita ça fait plus d'une semaine qu'ils
ont quittée punta arenas
ils n'ont pas à ses péchés pour
rembourser ne serait-ce que leurs frais
de gasoil
le temps passe il faut impérativement
que la chance tourne
[Musique]
taha
hector qui fait un froid de diable mais
[__] ça gèle
ah là là ouais non
du coup là
à la ramasse et le passage de la marine
y'a pas des pêcheurs qui ont disparu
dans trois oui
avant oui il ya des pêcheurs qui sont
morts par ici
on
qu'est ce qui les pousse ces pêcheurs de
patagonie à braver le froid les
intempéries
à vivre isolement et la promiscuité
pourquoi el chino tuyaux et flash ils
reviennent toujours
[Musique]
il y est l'argent mais il n'est pas
vraiment au bout de leur voyage
peut-être que c'est simplement la vie la
moins pire
et tu commences à avoir du vide je crois
pas qu'ils soient gonflés
c'est la bonne vie et l'eau peu de honte
c'est pas bon c'est pas beau mon gars
[Musique]
pour
de même
on
[Musique]
voilà rien rien du tout
je sens plus mes bras c'est pas notre
jour
ces mauvais tout ça est sûrement des
bateaux qui sont déjà passés
madonna et en plus il ya plein d'algues
ouais il reste des algues centre est
longue
on descend on reste ici en rouge
et voici mon [__] qu'est ce qu'on fait
bon alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
bon
toujours ce maudit vent d'ouest là
découvrir
[Musique]
satané grain va nous arriver dessus
ce sera le temps de merde
on sait aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
incroyable trop c'est trop
aucune pêche n'est bonne aucune paix ça
cette saison c'est la catastrophe mais
on va tenir
[Applaudissements]